[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand j'étais enfant j'étais toujours
les autres et surtout ceux qui ne
savaient pas défendre et il faut dire
que je ne me laisserai pas faire non
plus je me souviens d'une anecdote un
jour je rentre de la maternelle et je
demande à ma tante qui me gardait de
boire du lait jusque là tout va bien
c'est normal j'adore le lait dit hâtif
te plaît de moduler ali est hâtif te
plaît sauf que je demande un deuxième
verre puis un autre et un autre encore
alors quand même un peu étonnée elle me
dit mais dis-moi vanessa mais pourquoi
tu bois du lait comme ça je sais que tu
adores ça mais quand même ton bois pas
autant d'habitudes à lydie moyens il ya
un truc
bah en fait tati c'est pour prendre des
forces parce qu'à une fille à l'école
qui m'a attaquée elle m'a donné un coup
de pied alors bah moi tu sais quoi je
vais lui en 2002 ah bon mais pourquoi 2
bat ses sympathies 1 pour celui qu'elle
m'a donné et inde avance et toc
d'aussi loin que je puisse me souvenir
j'ai toujours eu une âme d'héroïne
j'avais cette valeur amour très forte
qui me poussait à aider et protéger tout
le monde en fait je ne supportait pas de
voir des personnes que j'aime et
souffrir je préférais prendre cette
souffrance pour moi à la maison comme
dans toutes les familles s'étaient pas
toujours facile alors comme j'étais une
petite fille curieuse et que j'avais
beaucoup d'imagination
je crée des histoires extraordinaires
avec mes peluche aimé bonhomme du coup
ça nous faisait tous rire et le climat
s'apaise
et puis un jour je me retrouve seule
avec un ami de la famille qui aime bien
me prendre sur ses genoux
en plus tout le monde adore et là
peu de temps après je me suis mise à
avoir très mal à l'oreille d'un seul
coup à souffrir le martyre il s'est
passé quelque chose à ce moment là de
très dur de très difficile à digérer
pour moi et mon corps réagit de façon
très violente
à partir de là je ne sais pas pourquoi
mais j'ai eu du mal à entendre et à
pleurer
j'ai même failli devenir sourn en fait
je ne suis fait violer et je me suis
coupé une mes émotions je garde tout en
moi je suis une héroïne moi alors j'ai
mis mon masque de sauveuse pour me
protéger et sauver toute ma famille et
puis après j'ai fait du karaté
parce que bon on n'avait pas acheter des
bouteilles de lait tout le temps je peux
me défendre tout seul moi je suis une
héroïne moi je ne pleure pas je défends
mes copains à l'école
ensuite je me suis retrouvé à dos
j'avais mon corps qui se transformait je
devenais une belle jeune fille j'étais
jolie tellement jolie que mon frère m'a
à dori à un point vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer il faut dire qu'on lui a décelé
de schizophrénie et il avait beaucoup
d'admiration pour moi il est tombé
amoureux de sa soeur il s'est passé ce
qui s'est passé je ne sais pas pourquoi
je me suis laissé faire
il était malade et je veux protéger ma
famille parce que c'est ce que j'aime le
plus faire au monde depuis que je suis
enfant protéger mon clan ma famille mes
copains à l'école je n'avais plus mes
peluche aimé bonhomme alors je suis
devenu écrivain pour moi je me suis mise
à écrire des histoires d'héroïne où je
me voyais sauver le monde
c'était mon univers mon monde
mon autre réalité et puis un jour
ouah il y règne akimov des fleurs dans
le métro c'est fou j'ai jamais eu cette
attention là je suis père touché
si vous saviez en vrai très charmant
on a rit on a discuté et tu me dis qu'on
va se revoir on va pas se quitter comme
ça
j'invite une amie à venir avec moi il
aura un ami lui aussi on va boire un
verre on mange ensemble on s'amuse bien
c'est vraiment chouette la vie est belle
vraiment j'ai 18 ans vous avez vu comme
je suis super on décide d'aller chez lui
tous les quatre
sauf que là les événements prennent une
autre tournure ces salopards omis la
drogue dans nos verres nos corps se sont
figés on ne peut plus bouger
à ce moment là je comprends qu'il va se
passer quelque chose d'horrible
alors je remets une nouvelle fois mon
costume d'héroïne et je vais négocier
avec ses violeurs pour qu'il n'arrive
rien à mon ami pour la protéger elle
qu'il ne s'en prenne qu'à moi sauf que
là pour la première fois quelqu'un a été
témoin elle a tout entendu
elle a entendu que je me faisais violée
et là mon costume d'héroïne en a pris un
sacré coup
c'est le cas de liens car elle m'a
ouvert les yeux tu te rends compte de ce
qui s'est passé là vanessa c'est pas
normal
tu t'es sacrifier pour me sauver tu t'es
fait violer c'est grave
tu es une victime non je ne suis pas une
victime
je suis une héroïne à nous
je ne suis pas une héroïne en fait non
c'est pas possible
ma vie n'est pas du tout celle que je
croyais imaginez un peu toutes mes
émotions me sont remontés à la figure un
véritable électrochoc et j'ai revu tout
le film de ma vie défiler devant mes
yeux un cauchemar une abomination une
souffrance effroyable mais tellement
forte
une douleur à en crever j'ai envie de me
faire mal je ne peux pas accepter d'être
une victime pendant douze ans c'est long
12 ans je ne les ai pas vus j'ai tout
fait pour ne pas le voir ne pas
l'entendre
j'étais dans le déni complet complet
alors évidemment je dégringole
je vais rencontrer un autre univers pour
m'évader rencontré mon autre héroïne
maintenant je vais vous raconter tout
processus il m'a fallu du temps avant
d'accepter ça a été un mal nécessaire
j'ai même failli me tuer mais c'est
après ma tentative de suicide que j'ai
réellement pris conscience et ça a été
le début de la renaissance
car à partir de là je me suis fait aider
j'ai lâché prise et j'ai accepté d'être
une victime est de faire tomber mon
masque de sauveuse car oui j'étais bien
une victime avec un masque de sauveuse
alors pour d'autres personnes ce sera le
masque du perfectionnisme de l'obsession
du sport du contrô lent ou voir même du
narcissisme j'ai tué l'ancien vanessa
j'ai accepté de mourir de faire mourir
mon personnage qui faisait semblant que
tout allait bien
après j'ai reçu beaucoup d'amour même de
personnes que je n'imaginais pas je ne
croyais pas être aimé mais comment
aurait pu l'être en fait puisque je
n'étais pas moi et pourtant j'étais
beaucoup plus aimé que ce que je pensais
j'ai accepté d'être vulnérables et plus
tard j'en ai fait une véritable force je
pouvais enfin être moi et je suis devenu
authentique mais ce n'est pas venu tout
de suite bien sûr parce qu'entre mai 20
et 25 ans j'ai été en iran ce total car
oui j'ai pris conscience que je veux
changer mais ça ne s'est pas fait comme
ça du jour au lendemain ça a été un
véritable chemin
en plus je ne savais pas du tout par où
commencer
j'étais complètement perdu j'ai donc
cherché à me faire aider chacun à sa
manière et va vivre le processus
alors c'est vrai je vous ai raconté mon
histoire et je suis un peu un cas
extrême parce que j'ai vécu des viols
multiples mais vous savez pour d'autres
personnes
ce sera du harcèlement moral une
agression un burnout ou toute autre
forme de violence physique
d'ailleurs à ce stade j'aimerais
préciser quelque chose de très important
je ne m'adresse pas qu'aux femmes les
hommes aussi subissent des violences en
plus quel que soit le degré de
souffrance que l'on puisse vivre
nous ne pouvons jamais la minimiser la
souffrance ni même la comparer elle est
tellement propre à chacun de nous par
contre le processus lui se construit
exactement de la même façon entre le
moment où l'on réalise et le passage à
l'action
il peut se passer du temps pour s'en
sortir et c'est normal
mais dès lors que j'étais dans cette
démarche
j'ai continué à chercher et à
expérimenter et je suis tombé sur un psy
coach plus coach que psy d'ailleurs qui
a été mon mentor
il m'a fait comprendre toutes les étapes
par lesquelles j'étais passé il m'a
permis de réaliser que j'avais mis en
place des mécanismes de défense très
puissants ainsi que tout un processus de
transformation que je voudrais illustré
grâce à la courbe du deuil que l'on doit
à la psychiatre elisabeth kübler-ross et
que l'on appelle aussi la courbe du
changement et que j'imagine un certain
nombre d'entre vous connaît déjà mais
vous savez les mécanismes de défense que
j'ai mis en place à l'époque m'ont été
très utile mais c'est un vrai leur bien
sûr et je vous explique pourquoi le choc
le premier viol que j'ai subis et qui
m'a enfermée dans le déni le déni à le
déni le déni je suis resté bloqué dans
cette phase pendant 12 ans mais si à 6
ans j'avais vraiment réalisé ce qui
m'arrivait je crois que j'aurais été
complètement détruite je me suis donc
coupé du monde réel pour me protéger en
même temps et même si c'est terrible à
dire c'est aussi cette phase de déni où
l'on refuse de voir la réalité en face
qui fait que l'on reproduit sans arrêt
les mêmes schémas mentaux
tant que l'on en n'a pas pris conscience
c'est ainsi que moi je suis passé de
choc dénis dénis choc
est ce donc pendant 12 ans alors pour
compléter un peu plus mon propos sur
cette phase
j'aimerais vous parler du triangle
dramatique victime sauveur bourreau
alors si certains d'entre vous ne
connaissent pas les concepts que
j'évoque ou tout simplement si vous êtes
curieux je vous invite à aller visiter
un très bon ami à moi je l'adorent moi
c'est google
il a réponse à tout enfin presque
n'exagérons pas alors pour en revenir au
triangle dramatique
je me suis enfermé dans ce rôle de
sauveuse mois toujours pour ne pas voir
la réalité en face
j'ai donc attirer des victimes et des
bourreaux et moi je ne voulais surtout
pas être une victime alors je m'étais
inventé une vie qui n'était pas la
mienne pour me protéger et protéger les
autres en fait à ce moment là de ma vie
je suis dissocier je ne prends pas soin
de mes besoins
pour ne pas avoir à affronter la douleur
aussi quand toutes mes émotions remonte
et me saute à la figure
c'est un véritable cataclysme autant je
suis resté enfermé dans le déni pendant
12 ans autant de 18 à 20 ans boom tout
s'accélère la colère c'est insupportable
j'ai une rage en moi et je veux me
détruire
puis vient la peur en fait je commence à
comprendre que je suis une victime
j'ai mal je souffre mais à ce moment là
j'ai j'ai terriblement peur de revivre
ça à nouveau négociations je ne sais
plus du tout qui je suis une partie de
moi a toujours envie d'être cette
héroïne mais je n'y croit plus vraiment
j'ai jamais été réellement moi j'ai
toujours fait semblant ma vie n'a plus
aucun sens la souffrance est trop forte
je suis anéantie je m'étais complètement
oublié pendant toutes ces années je
n'avais pas réalisé à quel point on
m'avait fait balle et le pire le pire
dans tout ça c'est que je n'avais plus
la force
là on arrive un petit peu vraiment dans
la phase hop le fond du trou comme on
dit on mais le lâcher prise
j'en peux plus je vais même jusqu'au
suicide
je fais tomber mon masque je tue mon
ancien mois et de la ma vraie
personnalité jaillit ensuite on arrive
donc dans toute la phase ascendante avec
l'acceptation alors l'acceptation c'est
quand même un peu une phrase ambiguë ou
en tout cas une phase de transition
avait quand même une période
d'instabilité
parce que oui bien sûr j'ai réalisé que
je veux changer
j'accepte d'être une victime et de vivre
ma souffrance mais le processus prend du
temps aussi
j'expérimente différents chemins pour me
faire accompagner et je rencontre mon
mentor et là c'est une véritable
renaissance pour moi ou peut-être même
devrais je dire une naissance à partir
de mes 25 ans tout change
le pardon je peux enfin être moi et
vivre ma vie je me pardonne et je
pardonne aux autres et waouh ça fait
tellement du bien d'être en paix
quête de sens au fur et à mesure des
séances avec mon mentor j'ai un
véritable déclic je réécris ma vie en
écoutant mes émotions toutes mes
émotions et ça devient comme une
évidence pour moi de devenir coach
d'accompagner j'ai toujours été fait
pour ça alors je passe à l'action
je fais le grand saut je me forme à
différentes techniques de coaching et de
terreur et de thérapies brèves et
aujourd'hui ça fait plus de dix ans que
je suis coach que j'accompagne mais je
ne retombe plus en triomphe dramatique
ça c'est fini je ne sors plus je donne
des clés je suis moi authentique
cette femme qui aime l'humain plus que
tout je pourrais même vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui je suis mon propre leader
et que ma vulnérabilité
c'est ma plus grande force pour
découvrir son vrai soin et se révéler il
faut oser être dans l'avenir habilité
c'est à dire se regardent et honnêtement
dans une glace et oui oui je sais je
peux vous le dire ce n'est pas facile
c'est pour cela qu'il est important
d'accepter de demander de l'aide de
faire le travail sur soi d'enlever le
masque est de parcourir le chemin avec
courage moi j'ai osé enlever le mien et
vous oserez vous enlevez le vôtre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci